[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive uh it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political journalists at the
financial times jasmine cameron shileshi
and
deputy political editor at the spectator
and columnist at the ikt balls they will
be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's have a look at what's on some
of those front pages
the eye leads with the ukraine crisis
and russia's move into the donbass
region it says president putin has taken
europe to the brink of war
in the telegraph u.s president joe biden
says russia has already started to
invade ukraine and is preparing to
advance deeper into the country the male
has the same lead with president biden
describing putin as twisted and ready
for bloodshed
this is the times that west imposes
sanctions as biden warns of war
the financial times pictures russian
tanks on the border with ukraine and
says vladimir putin is backing the
separatists claims across the whole
donbass region not just the parts they
already hold
that according to the guardian means the
threat of war is growing
the metro leads with the uk sanctions
against russia with the headline will
grab him by the rubles the star says
that'll learn him
uh while the express reports that more
and even tougher sanctions are yet to
follow
but the mirror says that many people are
angry that not enough is being done to
rid the uk of billions of dollars of
dirty russian money and the sun reports
the government will send more weapons to
ukraine within days uh and a reminder
that by scanning the qr code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers uh all whilst watching us
uh and tonight we are joined by jasmine
cameron chuleshi and katie ball so let's
get straight into the papers there's a
lot to talk about uh tonight starting
with the eye there and a really
arresting front page with the russian
tanks on it putin takes europe to the
brink
of war we heard from anthony blinken the
u.s secretary of state earlier that uh
this is the biggest threat to europe
since uh world war ii is it the brink
of war katie or are we already there
well
we know things are not in a good place
ultimately and i think the question is
just what exactly is putin planning and
we're still not completely sure
i think that the problem is that the
worst fears of nato allies the uk and
the us is that actually we could be
heading to a much wider invasion
and then i think many had thought would
be was a more likely solution and
wireless has um uh or approached by by
russia and i think while this initially
began you know with uh you know
rebel-held territories you can already
see putin expanding beyond that and
where does this all lead and i think
that there's a very ominous feeling in
government here in um london and
westminster tonight and a sense that
this is going to not end well and we're
heading to potentially you know weeks
and months of conflict
certainly uh some quite dark language on
the front of the eye there uh we are on
the precipice of a dark and dangerous
era says the us uh
full-scale invasion all-out attack it's
it's that that's the real question isn't
it jasmine is how far putin uh is going
to go with this and on the front of the
financial times putin backs separatist
claims to the whole donbass region of
ukraine of course we know now that um
the separatists only have a third of the
donbass region
is this a pretext for putin to go
further but how far
i mean quite possibly and as katie says
there's still a lot of uncertainty as to
what putin's calculating and what his
intentions are for the region but i
think we got a sense of that in his
quite rambling speech earlier in the
week where he basically tried to rewrite
ukrainian history and really undermine
the sense that we've had since the since
the cold war that european countries
have a right to determine their own
destinies and the right to determine
their own democracies and so the feeling
is quite ominous there is a sense that
putin's been quite calculated and how
he's approached the situation sort of
taking small steps escalating the crisis
bit by bit seeing how the western allies
will respond and so he's giving western
countries in the ukraine very limited
options as days go by there's a sense
that the window for diplomacy in the
window to to de-escalate the situation
is now sort of shrinking and that this
is all moving in one direction and i
think the sort of progression from
supporting these rebel groups to
actually taking over potentially larger
chunks of territory sort of just shows
the trajectory of travel at the moment
certainly not looking good uh the metro
uh is is leading on this as well as so
many of the papers are we'll grab him by
the rubles i mean it's a funny headline
but it's a really serious uh subject
here these are the sanctions uh the uk
well the west in general imposing new
sanctions
uh what do you make of the sanctions
katie that certainly the uk have imposed
well i think the reaction has been uh
one of almost you know lots of people i
think are underwhelmed i think i would
include many tory mps than that and yes
a select number of banks and you know
oligarchs have been named as those who
face sanctions but if you look at the
german response and it's worth pointing
out that the german government has been
heavily criticized in recent weeks for
not taking a tough enough stance on
russia i think today um the announcement
that nordstrom 2 the energy uh the
pipeline on the gas pump line is being
stalled you look at that very drastic
has taken lots of people by surprise and
you look at the sanctions the uk is
announcing and it doesn't seem to match
that if you think about the role the
city of london plays when it comes to
russian money now uk government sources
say well this is just the beginning
we're doing this in stages so there
clearly is more to come
but i think right now i think there are
a few uh tory mps you're saying well
this can't be it uh the government does
need to go further and funny enough the
mat uh cartoon in the telegraph uh
invoking that same uh feeling no russian
oligarchs uh it says
uh there of course this sense that well
certainly uh bill browder the campaigner
the anti-corruption campaigner has made
it clear that the three oligarchs named
by
the uk and their sanctions have been on
the u.s sanctions list since 2018. so
he's calling those uk sanctions fairly
uh tepid jasmine what do you make of the
sanctions if they are your only tool and
at the moment they are because there's
no uh indication there is absolutely no
intention to to put boots on the ground
um if sanctions your only weapon do you
have to hold back the most important
ones i think there is an argument for
doing so because at the point where
they've definitely ruled out um troops
on the ground there are only so many
tools that they haven't at their
disposal but i think there is an
argument that by
imposing these sanctions that are quite
weak compared to if we look at what
germany has done and what the u.s is
suggesting
it it does sort of undermine uk
leadership on this and it does
potentially give russian oligarchs and
russian businesses time to sort of
move their um you know finances and make
arrangements that even if tougher
sanctions come they've been forewarned
of that but i think there isn't on the
flip side you can argue that actually
the kremlin has been quite firm and said
that for every sanction there's going to
be retaliations and whether that's cyber
attacks um or if we're looking at energy
and so perhaps a more slower steady
approach that gives the uk and western
allies to prepare for any sort of
reprisals as well yeah i mean there is
the problem as well that any sanctions
will hurt the uk and the u.s the west as
much as they hurt russia potentially the
daily telegraph business page certainly
has this putin attack intensifies living
cost uh crisis for the uk katie what do
you make of that
yeah i think that we've heard these
warnings and actually boris johnson i
think has probably been uh one of the uh
least direct leaders i'm talking about
this um joe biden it's been quite clear
that uh you know if if you impose
sanctions um you too will you know feel
some kickback from that
and i think that's something that we're
clearly going to feel in terms of you
know fuel gas
and lots of questions and you're seeing
warnings even from russian politicians
saying uh well this is the decision of
europeans to spend you know large sums
of money on energy by taking these
decisions so there's clearly a trade-off
um is it avoidable um i think that
clearly it's a very difficult situation
and it seems to be
pretty inevitable this is going to
happen if you are going to take a stance
against russia and as for what it's
going to do i mean the difficulty is
we're already heading to a cost of
living crisis probably going to start
really uh feeding money are still but
ultimately a lot of people are going to
feel even more in the spring and this is
simply going to add to that further
um and probably also i think speed up
efforts to look for different um energy
supplies and
and so forth but it's going to be
painful and that's before we even get to
potential other ways this could kick
back on us such as potential cyber
attacks yeah absolutely well listen
we're gonna have to leave ukraine there
for now plenty more to come
later in the programme including uh more
on the leaked document that showed
scotland yard questioned under caution
those who attended those downing street
parties we'll have more on that with our
guests after the break
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview uh with me now and all evening
our political journalist at the
financial times jasmine cameron chileshi
and deputy political editor at the
spectator and columnist at the eye katie
balls uh so back to our papers and uh
well i guess if you thought you could
get through a day without talking about
party gate you'll be sorely disappointed
but the front page of the telegraph uh
here downing street party attendees
questioned
under police caution jasmine why is that
so important
i mean i think it really highlights the
um severity of um the alleged law
breaking and it it really
it speaks to whether there was
criminality in some of these proceedings
as well and i think as you said we sort
of thought that we'd got away from this
story but it's reared its head up again
and i think for johnson he's been
preoccupied with ukraine and he's been
able to point to ukraine and say you
know there's more important things going
on you know we should be focusing on the
situation in europe not whether or not i
had a birthday cake i was in a room for
25 minutes but the story really isn't
going away and we know that johnson's
handed in his questionnaire and there
are still some
still some more people to hand their
questionnaires in and i think you know a
big part of johnson's political future
is really riding on the outcome of this
met investigation and what is um
revealed in the updated secret report
which we're expecting after as well and
so i think this certainly isn't the end
of this saga and this is just one of the
many twists to this story and it has i
mean if it is under caution if this is
true uh it's those immortal words you do
not have to say anything uh but it may
harm your defense if you do not mention
when questioned et cetera et cetera et
cetera uh to have that to a prime
minister i mean when it happened when
when tony blair was under investigation
for cash for honors he was told
apparently according to this article
that if he was questioned under caution
it would be a resigning matter katie how
i mean is this a resigning matter for
boris johnson i mean has it been a
resigning matter all along
well we know the prime minister doesn't
plan to resign
um i didn't necessarily answer the
question whether it's resigning matter
but not from boris johnson's perspective
and i think that
clearly it's serious and this is a
questionnaire so we are taking from this
and this is the implication and the
telegraph and other papers that this
means prime minister has been
interviewed under caution that is more
serious in that case than what happened
when it came to tony blair
and but where does this all lead i think
it is quite tricky to predict right now
because when it comes to the partygate
story often comes in waves
right now i think the past week and a
half and we have been in recess things
have seemed calm of the prime minister
but ultimately the police investigation
is coming up the track and if he is
fined i think even if lots of younger
staff members find and he is not you
know all these scenarios are quite
tricky for him
and ultimately you then have the
situation of does the prime minister
publish the secret report he suggested
he will in the chamber there's still
some skepticism in government he's
really going to publish the thing so
there's lots of chances his story to
erupt again and that's before you even
get to dominic cummings what he might
blog or tweet and potential leaks of
various photos that we know the police
have yeah absolutely well listen he's
had enough to distract him for the
moment thank you very much jasmine and
katie